foreign
I want to start off the show with
something that grinds my gears can we do
that let's do it George and that is the
iPad tipping screens and we all agree we
need to be done with those thank God
somebody said something George so Rachel
Cruz and I we've got our smart money
Happy Hour podcast and the most popular
episode we've ever done was called guilt
tipping I listened to All About The
Tipping culture in today's in America
especially this is not a problem in
Europe apparently I hope it doesn't
spread over there no that's not the
culture at all you don't matter of fact
it's kind of like frowned upon it's like
if it was amazing you give them a little
bit yeah sure sure because you get a
living wage but here in America we
decided no make the people tip when you
just ordered your black coffee and they
spin around the iPad and they start
complimenting you yeah and you
subconsciously feel guilty and go uh the
options are 20 40 and 1 000 tip I don't
know that I feel guilty George
well you're a better person I think I
feel more irritated well I now hit no
tip exclamatory
they need to put an exclamation point no
tip exclamation let's be clear we're all
about generosity here we're not talking
about not tipping your servers not
tipping your Barbers we are talking
about those little iPads when you are
sitting there and someone just rang you
up and you have a salad you've got no
service for food yet that's right and
they're saying how much do you want to
tip and the preset amounts keep
increasing 20 22 one time there was one
that was 33 percent I saw this with my
own Brown eyeballs
now here's the thing and and you said it
George this is this is very clear we
have to be crystal clear for the people
restaurant service places where you're
not earning your your hourly wage your
hourly wage is tips we support you
matter of fact tip those people 25 tip
them as much as you can and if you can't
do that then please don't go don't go
out don't go out to eat but I'm talking
about I bought a salad and I haven't
even gotten to see yet did you make it
with no bacon like I asked I'll take the
bacon Jade please don't ever waste it
yeah you know I'll get a little side you
can have the little side thing of bacon
George well there's an article here and
this is spreading now like wildfire the
Hill Covered this here's their headline
why are the default tipping screens set
so high and of course they start the
article with a very clever line have we
reached a tipping Tipping Point very
clever that sounds like something you
might say we should have stolen that
that's good I like this part it says
it's hard to know for sure whether more
establishments are accepting or
soliciting tips then say a decade ago
it's not hard to tell
it's not hard we are everywhere you go
there's that little iPad it doesn't
matter if it's coffee
salad
doesn't matter where you go it's not
hard these tech service type places yeah
especially that are guilty of this and
uh here's a quote people think it's
manipulative they resent it and their
perceptions of service go down and there
is guilt involved there's one ice cream
place locally I won't mention the name
because I'm a big fan of their ice cream
I know what you're talking about they
are the service isn't great but all of a
sudden when they ring you up they get
real chatty and real nice okay I don't
like that that's not complimenting me as
they're turning around the hey how's
your day going oh that's that's good to
hear I love that shirt love the GLA love
those glasses huh you don't believe that
they love your shirt and glasses no I
believe they want to get in my mind
subconsciously while I'm trying to
choose a tip
nefarious gross man you know here's
where I'm at with this George and and
you this is my personal take and here's
why I get frustrated slash irritated we
already have inflation right which is
already built into the cost of our food
not just groceries people when you go to
the restaurants it's there and we know
that that rate's somewhere around 11.4
percent then you've got the tip 20 and
then for you people out there who are
using credit cards
I hope you're not the average credit
card interest rate 19.20 George do you
see what I'm getting at here I just
threw up in my mouth a little do you see
where I'm getting at we're we're I'm not
not me because your girl's not using
credit cards we're not doing that but
the people out there who are engaging in
that way of life they're paying a
premium of over 50 percent
for that's why the tip screen I I gotta
just say no just say no if you want to
hear more on this topic go check out
that smart money Happy Hour episode
called guilt tipping how to deal with an
absurd tipping culture you can just
search smart money happy hour wherever
you listen to podcasts and uh if you're
calling in today we'd love to hear your
thoughts on tipping culture and uh if
you're if you're an iPad Tipper and if
you are why did you choose to do that
because you're just perpetuating the
problem at that point yeah well you
could budget for it
that is true there's that and I'm not
saying I never do it what I'm saying in
general if there was no service provided
yeah it's a no tip I'd rather save it
I'd rather save it for the the Food
Service workers amen